you are watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video what
comes to your mind when I say Walt
Disney some of you might think of
classic cartoons and modern-day movie
masterpieces others a grand theme park
or a mass media holding company and
others still a man
all of these are accurate but what's the
story behind the Walt Disney Company and
how big are they today as we all know is
started with a man named Walt Disney a
sure genius but the details of his life
and the aspects that made him different
from others are hazy too most Walt
Disney was an ambitious innovator he
seemed to never give up he also had
another side he was a perfectionist who
was particularly Stern to those he
worked with in this video we'll learn
all about Walt and the company he
created which is still relevant a better
part of a century later let's begin born
in Chicago 1901 Walt was a pretty
regular kid of the day and one of five
children during primary school he
expressed an interest in drawing and
would practice sketching by copying the
front page of his dad's newspaper after
a while
Walt's dad got the boy some drawing
lessons and he would subsequently draw
for his high school paper but the thing
was nobody thought of him as a
particularly great artist at age 17 Walt
decided to send some of his drawings to
magazines for publication but they were
all rejected rejection and persistence
would be all too familiar to Walt over
the next few years in 1919 Walt finally
got a job at the Peston Rubin commercial
art studio but was laid off a year later
after a failed attempt at starting an
animation studio of his own with an
ex-coworker
Walt landed another job at the Kansas
City film company this is where Walt was
first introduced to animated cartoons
his eyes were opened to a new world the
1920s was when animation really started
taking off in the form of silent short
comedy sketches Walt saw what was going
on around him and took inspiration he
borrowed a book on animation and a
camera and began to start shooting his
own cartoons in a shed behind his house
during his work in the shed Disney came
across a superior animation technique to
the one that was used at the Kansas ad
company where he worked after failing to
persuade his boss to use the better
animation method Disney continued to
work on his own cartoons by himself and
would call these cartoons laugh-o-grams
laugh-o-gram would end up being the name
of Walt's first animation studio which
he created shortly after at the age of
20 most people would be conservative
with their first business venture but
Walt was passionate he went out and
spent all of his investment money on
hiring animators for a film called
Alice's Wonderland based on the 1865
novel Alice's Adventures in Wonderland
this project was one of the first
instances of Walt's creative genius he
is why you see all the experimental
films of the day combined live-action
backgrounds with an animated character
on top what reversed this for Alice's
Wonderland putting the live-action
character within an animated world
unfortunately Walt's grand plan didn't
catch and halfway through production in
1923 the studio went into bankruptcy but
Disney still knew where his passion lay
he wanted to be an artist
he sold his camera and went to Hollywood
the center of the cartoon industry at
the time Walt would later state that
it's important to have a failure when
you're young while in Hollywood the
starry-eyed young man asked all the big
studios to take him on they all said no
won't finally got lucky when he managed
to sell a half-finished version of
Alice's Wonderland to a New York film
distributor landing a contract for two
seasons to make the short episodes of
the Alice films Walt teamed up with his
brother Roy who was living in Hollywood
at the time and formed the Walt Disney
Company by 1927 Disney had gotten sick
of the Alice series and wanted to make
some purely animated pieces his first
project was a series of short films
about a rabbit called Oswald
surprisingly the Oswald episodes got
distributed by Universal and made its
way into major theaters in 1928 when it
came time to renew the contract of
Oswald the rabbit Universal refused and
decided to produce the character
themselves this was actually a common
practice at the time as the
distributor's owned the complete rights
to the characters Disney once again was
left out in the cold but instead of
calling it quits he decided that he
needed a new character on the train home
with some of his family members
he was brainstorming I think he'll be a
mouse and I'll call him Adama he stated
Walt's mother strongly recommended that
the name of the character should be
Mickey Walt still struggled to find a
distributor for this new character and
he knew that he needed to do something
revolutionary here he capitalized on a
brand new technology that had just been
incorporated into the film industry
sound Walt knew that he had to do it
better than anyone else to succeed and
he is how he did it now we used to put
the sound on afterwards and in those
days you couldn't do what we call
dubbing today where you could mix a lot
of tracks and it wasn't yet science that
that you could get away with so we used
to have to do everything at one time
and we used to have to run the cartoon
we'd have the fellas with the sound
effects we had the people with the
voices we had the orchestra going and
everybody had to synchronize back in
1928 this was revolutionary people
wouldn't have been able to comprehend
that
animated character could whistle sing
and have corresponding sounds on film
Disney had just pioneered fully
synchronized sound for cartoons many
Harold this as the start of the Disney
we know today audiences had seen
cartoons would sound before but never
synchronized yet alone as perfectly as
this they were blown away Mickey in a
synchronized sound had made Walt famous
after this revolutionary innovation
Disney kept pushing the boundaries of
animation and when 1934 came around he
and his team got to work on the biggest
animation project ever undertaken the
first full color feature animated film
costing 1.5 million dollars it was
called Snow White
after Snow White came many meticulously
animated masterpieces like Pinocchio
Fantasia and Bambi despite all this
Disney wasn't going to stop at just film
in the 1950s he would focus his
attention on something completely
different theme parks traditionally
amusement parks were only for children
leaving tag-along parents with nothing
to do disney envisioned a place where
both children and parents could share
fun experiences together this place was
Disneyland and it was opened on July
17th of 1955 over the next few decades
Disney would break new ground in many
areas of film animation TV and even
technology in 1959 Disney would also
pioneer 360 video the technique then
called circle vision 360 used nine
cameras to stitch together a 360 video
for nine screens in a custom theater
in 1963 Disneyland featured
electromechanical robots this was the
first time people had ever seen such
lifelike technology some early visitors
thought the robots were actually actors
by this stage the creative direction of
the company was unstoppable
you
ninety-two years after its founding
Disney is a massive media powerhouse
it's absolutely huge but of course we're
here to find out exactly how big let's
start with the physical size Disney
World located in Orlando Florida covers
43 square miles that's about twice the
size of Manhattan or roughly the size of
San Francisco Epcot which stands for
experimental prototype community of
tomorrow is the biggest of the four
theme parks in Disney World and was
actually envisioned by Walt to be a
livable futuristic city recently Disney
also opened a Disneyland in China making
it their largest foreign investment ever
in terms of media here is a selection of
some well-known companies owned by
Disney
we have Walt Disney Pictures Disney
nature DisneyToon Studios Lucasfilm
which brought a Star Wars of course and
it was purchased by Disney in 2012 for
4.06 billion and then Pixar Animation
which actually grew out of Lucas Films
graphics department in 1979 and was
bought by Disney in 2006 Marvel Studios
bought in 2009 for four billion
touchstone pictures which gave us movies
like Sister Act Who Framed Roger Rabbit
and the Dead Poets Society we also have
Hollywood Records American Broadcasting
Company otherwise known as APC we have
ESPN a and E lifetime the History
Channel and the YouTube multi-channel
network maker studios Disney also partly
owns vice media in collaboration with
21st Century Fox so I'm just going to
ask some of you guys a quick question
did you know that Disney owned all of
those media companies I knew that they
owned some of those but not that much
and I think it's a little unnerving that
one company can own so much but I guess
it is what it is
next let's take a look at the financials
last year Disney made fifty two point
four six billion dollars in revenue with
a net income of eight point three eight
billion and it currently owns eighty
eight billion dollars in assets the
number of employees 180,000 for
comparison on the net income front
Microsoft comes in at about twelve point
two billion
alphabet comes in at sixteen point three
billion ExxonMobil twenty two billion
and Apple fifty three point four billion
all right so when you're in the end of
the video but before we finish off let's
take a look at ten crazy facts about the
Walt Disney Company number ten Sully
from monsters Inc has more than 2.3
million individual hairs a single frame
of Sully took an average of twelve hours
to produce number nine Disney pioneered
the storyboarding technique for
live-action film number eight Disney
World
every year the park finds an average of
6,000 cell phones 3,500 digital cameras
and 18,000 hats since 1971 1.6 million
pairs of sunglasses have been lost
number seven Walt Disney actually
decided to do the voice of Mickey Mouse
himself because he couldn't find anyone
else to do it the way he imagined in
Mickey was the first animated character
to ever talk his first words hot dog
number six Steve Martin used to work in
the magic shop at Disneyland in Los
Angeles number five it would take 68
years to sleep in every single one of
the rooms at Disney World
number four man in the forest was a code
used by animators to warn colleagues to
get back to work when Walt Disney was
coming down the hallway
number three Disney World flew its flags
at half-mast on the day that Steve Jobs
died jobs was Disney's largest single
shareholder at seven percent and was on
the board of directors number two Disney
World is second only to the US military
when it comes to purchasing explosives
in the United States
number one the ideas for wall-e Monsters
Inc a bug's life and Finding Nemo all
came from a single lunchtime
brainstorming session in 1994 this was
before the first Toy Story movie had
even been finished so there you have it
that's the history sighs and a few fun
facts about the Walt Disney Company
but when you think about it all if Walt
himself had given up when the Hollywood
studios had told him no or when his
character got stolen or at the failure
of his first two companies or when
people didn't think of him as a good
drawer in high school and refused to
publish his drawings none of this would
have ever happened people told him
repeatedly that he just wasn't a good
artist but he knew where his passion lay
and you have just seen the end result of
his work okay so that's the end of the
video thanks for watching feel free to
give this a thumbs up subscribe if
you're new to the channel and leave a
comment below
sharing a thought if you want to see
some more cool stuff look around on this
channel there's a bit of stuff for
everyone this has been to gogo you've
been watching cold fusion and I'll catch
you again soon for the next video thanks
guys have a good one
you
cold fusion it's me thinking